well let's now speak to Asama hamen
who's the amass spokesperson a very warm
welcome to you thank you very much for
joining us on Al jazer you join us of
course from from
beout I wonder if you can firstly React
to what we've heard in katar the there
seems to be a tremendous amount of
optimism coming from what we've heard so
far your
impressions well I have to start by
thanking our brothers in also in Egypt
for all the efforts which has been done
through the last three weeks it was a
very long way to achieve this uh
Arrangement uh the kares and the
Egyptians have done their best and in
fact uh we were supposed to achieve that
more than 10 days before but all the way
it was undermined by NY himself
yesterday he gave the green light for
death also without any
complications uh also that would open
the door for the humanitarian and
medical AIDS including the fuel for uh
the hospitals we hope that can go uh
smoothly uh and we trust all the efforts
which was done by the brothers in K are
you satisfied that everything you've
heard so far as a result of the these
negotiations will actually happen we're
talking of course about ending all
Israeli drone surveillance across Gaza
for several hours a day along with the S
of other military activity and indeed
arrests are you satisfied that those
demands will be met will be observed by
Israeli
forces well I have to say clearly that
the only thing which make uh the
Palestinian Nations feel satisfied the
end of the occupation and the end of the
Israeli attack against Gaza initi so
when we are talking about temporary C
that means what we have uh received as
Arrangements is good we accept that but
that is not the end of the road uh this
must be ended by a clear end for the
Israeli offensive attack on the
Palestinian people I have to remind
everyone that there was more than 14,000
Palestinians 75% of them were killed by
the Israeli bombardment on Gaza we are
talking about more than 30,000
Palestinian Palestinian injured more
than 7,000 Palestinians are still under
the rebel so we believe this time of
temporary C fa will help us in having
them back burying the Merit uh finding a
way to uh send those people who were
badly injured to have the medication but
the satisfaction will be at the moment
when everyone declares an end for the
incubation or an end for the Israeli
offensive attack on Gaza and a real
start and move a real actions to make an
end for the occupation on the
Palestinian lands how do you think that
this is likely to be responded to by of
course the many Palestinians there in
the gaza's trip who have been under
inscrutable pressure for the past few
weeks a tremendous civilian death toll
how do you think this is likely to be
received by those who have been bearing
the brunt of Israel's war on
Gaza well from uh the Palestinian point
of view the people and the resistance we
believe that this arrangement for those
four days is a very important
Arrangement the people can have the aid
can recover some of their issues can try
to find their beloved people where they
have gun here or there and this will be
a good chance for the Palestinians to
have some of their breath back after
more than 48 days of bombing Gaza so I
believe the Palestinians were waiting
for this Arrangements our people will be
they they are waiting and they are glad
I have to remind everyone that at the
same moment when the brothers in qar
declared the final
Arrangements alasam brigades declared a
complete positive reactions towards
towards that urging the people to act in
a positive way and we hope in
that will be the first step to achieve a
an end for the attack
against Hamden it's been important to
have you on the program many thanks for
that ham hamas's spokesperson